I created life and I created this in my  own image why not 40 years ago my father  David Harper jr. conducted the noble  experiment of producing plays for  television get too close we've been  logging that footage looking for insight  into my father he bit off a lot with  this play all pretending to be me dr.  Frankenstein well I pretend to be the  life that you've created in order to  secure funding from her who represents  the research in to do with my father  have a compulsion to court disaster  taking so long told you not to do Joey  was the hot young thing he and your  father would clash gonna be digging  you're gonna get dirt under your  fingernails they have to remove Ian else  what are you doing here threatening me  [Music]  so I got into Julliard making waves  hate secrets  you  [Music]  you